[Music]
stridor is the sort of man who flies a
hang-glider into a war zone he doesn't
get bogged down in the little details
and his latest hack and slash action
game is the same way without preamble or
pretext you're dropped straight into the
action cleaving through one hapless
guard after another Striders capacity
for carnage is boundless and the
acrobatic precision with which he
dispatches his foes makes him a delight
to control and as your arsenal grows so
too will your enjoyment of this
well-crafted game simply put Strider
feels great to play from the arc of his
jump to the range of his slide although
Striders movements are perfectly
measured to give you complete command
over the action in the beginning you can
do a little more than jump and slash but
by exploring the world and defeating
powerful bosses Strider unlocks new
techniques for his arsenal reflecting
bullets throwing knives and summoning an
eagle made of pure energy are just some
of the powers you earn and they expand
your fighting repertoire in new and
interesting ways unlocking new powers
also lets you unlock new doors each
upgrade for Striders weapon referred to
as a cipher unlocks a certain type of
door which means you'll need to
backtrack to previously explored areas
to either advance in the story or
discover unlockables such as concept art
or new costumes whilst Ryder's world is
filled with surprises the backdrop
itself is rather drab the moment you
touch down you're greeted with this
futuristic industrial aesthetic that
follows you wherever you go
admittedly this style does have the
benefit of making Strider and all his
Crimson scarfed glory pop against the
background but even so a little more
variety would have been welcomed certain
enemies also sport a splash of color to
indicate a weakness to a particular
cypher against such foes Strider must
switch to the appropriate cypher and use
it to disable the enemy's defenses these
enemies help keep fights feeling dynamic
as they force you to mix up your tactics
and utilise Strider to his fullest
once you've finished Striders made
adventure you can try your hand at the
game's challenge modes these challenges
come in two varieties survival and
beacon run
survival challenges are all about
testing your combat prowess while beacon
runs are all about speed and agility
beacon runs are especially welcome since
Strider is so fun to control and the
main game rarely tests your platforming
capabilities when a challenge is
completed you are graded on your
performance and can compare your stats
against others on challenge specific
leaderboards from the moment you embark
on your journey right up until the final
death blow Strider is a blast to play
controlling the agile ninja feels
empowering right out of the gate and
each new upgrade brings with it an
enjoyable new way to engage your foes
while his world is a little drab there's
still plenty to explore even after the
job is done Strider is fun pure and
simple and serves as a fitting revival
of a classic video game hero
[Music]